hi my name is couple neighbor Tia we're
into diamonds and jewelry manufacturing
it's probably the only one here from
this industry I wish more people from
our industry would attend events like
the World Economic Forum enjoyed the
sessions yesterday on corruption in
India and also mr. Pitroda session on
connecting India and developing India I
think the challenge before us is really
implementing the things that we learn
over here there's a lot of talk a lot of
debate but it's it's the people who
would really take it up and convert it
into action so I think we must all look
and see what we can do towards doing
that but thank you very much for having
me